大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
這一集,
我們上史丹佛大學的一門公開課,
叫人類行為生物學,
課號BO150,
2010年錄的,
講臺上是生物學家Robert Sapolsky,
這次一口氣上前,
八爬,
這八爬課都在回答一個你一定問過的問題,
一個人做了一件事,
是天生的還是後天的,
我先把答案放在前面,
這個問題本身問錯了,
基因很少直接下命令,
他說的多半是一句,
如果怎樣就怎樣,
而如果的那一半,
常常寫在身體外面,
所以這門課的第一句話是,
難的不是找到一個人,
而是找到一個人,
這個解釋是不要只住在一個解釋裡
我們分三步走
先看為什麼一個解釋不夠
再把基因拿出來
看他到底要來做什麼
最後問
到底能不能算出一個行為
有幾層是天生的
第七堂課
Sapolsky問了全班一個怪問題
一個人有幾根手指
跟一個人戴不戴耳環
哪一個比較由基因決定
你先猜一下
他的答案跟你想的剛好相反
這一題留到後面
先從一個40歲的男人開始
Sapolsky第一堂課一開口
就講了一個故事
一個40歲的男人
住在安靜的郊區
結婚很多年
有兩個孩子
生活一些正常
有一天
同事在飲水機旁邊
隨口評論了一支棒球隊
他一拳打在同事臉上
三個月後
太太發現他有外遇
再過三個月
他捲走公司的錢
從此消失
Sapolsky給了三個可能
第一個
這個人本來就是個壞人
第二個
他正在經歷一場
最幼稚的中年危機
第三個
他腦子裡有一個基因出了錯
最後一個聽起來最離譜
可是Sapolsky說
這正是某一種神經疾病的典型樣子
同一串行為
一個答案在講品格
一個在講人生階段
一個在講基因
你先想一下
你會選哪一個
麻煩的是你選哪一個
就決定了你會怎麼對待他
是責備他是勸他
也是帶他去看醫生
這一集的八草課
說穿了就在處理這一課
當三個答案同時擺在你面前
你要怎麼看
碰到這麼複雜的事
人最自然的做法就是分類
這個叫categorical thinking
中文叫類別思考
它的意思是
把一段連續的東西切成幾格
每一格貼一個名字
彩虹就是最好的例子
從紫到紅
光的顏色是連續的
中間有無限多種
可是我們把它切成紅、橙、黃、綠幾格
切成格子有好處
記起來神力
你不用記住那個顏色的每一個細節
只要記住它是橘色
可是格子也有代價
Sapolsky講了自己的糗事
有一次他打電話請教一位芬蘭籍的醫生
對方最後說你先拿一隻熊來練習
原來芬蘭話不分B跟P這兩個音
他說的是Pair離子
不是Bear熊
兩件事掉進同一格
你就分不出差別
反過來也會出錯
考試
65分跟66分其實差不多
可是齊格線剛好劃在中間
一分就變成天大的差別
Sapolsky
後來把這些格子叫做bucket
就是籃子
一句話說完
分類讓你記得住
也讓你看不清
放到科學上
每一門學問都是一籃子
Sapolsky用了一個老笑話
一隻母雞為什麼要過馬路
研究荷爾蒙的人會說
它血液裡的雌激素到了某個濃度
研究演化的人會說
一代又一代下來
不理會攻擊的母雞
留下的後代比較少
兩個答案都對
麻煩在於
住在一個籃子裡久了
就會覺得自己
那個籃子才是全部的解釋
Sepolsky唸了幾段話
證明這件事
其中一段是John Watson說的
他是心理學行為主義的
創始人之一
行為主義的意思是
人會變成什麼樣子
全看你怎麼獎勵他
怎麼懲罰他
Watson說
給我一個剛出生的小孩
讓我控制他長大的全部環境
我可以把他變成醫生
律師
乞丐
或者小偷
你聽得出來
這是把一切都丟進後天這個籃子
另一段來自
發明額葉切除手術的
Egasmonis
他臨諾貝爾講的時候說
這個手術沒有失敗
後來這個手術
做在非常多人身上
Sapolsky說
住錯籃子會有人受傷
請你記住Watson這句話
等我們開始算天生有幾成的時候
他會回來
那住在籃子裡要怎麼問
Sapolsky給的做法是
沿著時間往回問
這是整門課的工具
我們給它一個名字叫
從一秒前問到一千萬年前
你看到一個行為
先問一秒前
腦子裡哪些神經細胞被啟動了
再往前問
是什麼聲音或氣味讓它們啟動
再往前
過去幾個小時
血液裡的荷爾蒙
怎麼讓你對那個氣味更敏感
然後一路挽回
問到小時候
問到在媽媽兔子裡的時候
問到基因
最後問到這個物種
幾百萬年的演化
Sapolsky說
這些站其實連在一起
你說某個荷爾蒙造成這個行為
那個荷爾蒙是基因做出來的
你就已經在講遺傳
基因又被演化篩選過
你就已經在講演化
所以沒有籃子
只有暫時停下來的月臺
每一個月臺
都只是把前面發生過的一切
用最方便的方式說出來
這條路後面還會一直出現
每當有人說
這個行為就是某某造成的
你都可以問一句
那是哪一站
前一站呢
這條路最遠的一站是演化
我們就先走到那裡
第二堂課一開始
Sapolsky拿出兩個頭骨
一個母的 一個公的
他說
假設你在野外發現一個新物種
只剩下這兩個頭骨
只要手上有對的工具
你就能猜出這個物種
誰比較會出軌
公的有多兇
母的一胎生一個
還是生雙胞胎
他靠的是一個想法
你小時候看自然節目
常聽到一種說法
長頸鹿脖子那麼長
心臟一定很大
科學家一量
果然剛好
大自然真奇妙
Zapolsky說
不
這不奇妙
你想想看
長頸鹿的頭
比心臟高出好大一截
每一次心跳
都要把血往上
推到那麼高的地方
心臟不夠大
血送不上腦袋
這種動物根本活不下來
就不會有長頸鹿
所以不是剛好
是隻能這樣
有一條躲不掉的道理
決定了身體
要長成什麼樣子
這兩堂課要說的是
行為也躲不掉
同一條道理
那兩個頭骨
我們先放在桌上等規則講完再回來推
你會看到光靠骨頭能推出的東西多到讓人意外
這條道理要從達爾文講起
達爾文沒有發現演化
在他之前大家就知道物種會變
他提出的是演化怎麼發生
這個機制叫Natural Selection
中文叫天擇
它只有幾步
一個特徵能遺傳給下一代
每個個體身上有點不一樣
其中某些版本比較好用
好用的版本在族群裡就會越來越多
他有一句話要改掉
這不是適者生存
重點不是誰活得久
是誰在下一代留下比較多分基因
套到行為上
同樣幾步都神類
幾多一個假設
行為要能遺傳
意思是
一隻動物怎麼打架
怎麼照顧孩子
這些做法要有一部分
能從爸媽傳給孩子
天擇才塞得到他
請你記住這個假設
因為這一集的後半段
都在追問他
另外先說
好 後面我們會說
母猴想要這樣
公猴想要那樣
這只是方便的說法
他們沒有在盤算
是演化把那些行為
留了下來
就像我們說
水想往低處流
水其實什麼都沒想
接著
Sapolsky要丟掉一個
大家從小學到的觀念
你一定在自然節目看過這一幕
一大群腳馬走到河邊
對岸是青草
河裡全是鱷魚
大家在岸邊走來走去不敢下水
這時候一隻老腳馬擠到最前面
好像在說
孩子們我犧牲自己
然後跳進河裡
鱷魚忙著吃它
其他腳馬就從旁邊安全過河
節目會告訴你
動物會為了整個物種的好處行動
這個說法
有一個名字叫group selection
中文叫群體選擇
Zaposki說
研究的人盯著看夠久
才發現那隻老腳馬
那一隻
道理其實不難想
假設真的有一種腳馬
天生願意為大家犧牲
另一種不願意
願意犧牲的那種
一次一次跳進河裡
留下的孩子越來越少
不願意的那種
留下的孩子越來越多
幾代之後
願意犧牲的就不見了
所以Sapolsky說
動物做事
不是為了物種好
不是為了物種
那是為了什麼
為了讓自己的基因
在下一代留下
越多分越好
Sapolsky說
做到這件事
有三種做法
最直接的叫
Individual Selection
中文叫個體選擇
就是靠自己生
他引了一句話
一隻雞隻是一顆蛋
用來做出另一顆蛋的方法
主角是基因
雞隻是工具
第二種做法
繞了一個彎
叫Kind Selection
中文叫親屬選擇
你的親戚身上
有一部分跟你一樣的基因
越親一樣的越多
親兄弟姐妹大約一半
表姻弟姐妹大約八分之一
遺傳學家Howden傳說
在酒吧裡講過一句話
我願意為兩個心得
或者八個表情犧牲性命
這句話不是在講感情
是在講算術
兩個兄弟加起來
剛好等於一個你
八個表情也等於一個你
從這裡推出來
動物會照顧親戚
而且越親照顧的越多
你先留一個疑問在心裡
動物怎麼知道誰是他的兄弟
這一題
第八堂課才會
第三種做法是幫
沒有血緣的對象
叫reciprocal altruism
中文叫互惠利他
意思是你幫我抓被
我幫你抓被
他有一個條件
你付出的
不能比拿回來的多
所以互惠永遠跟作弊綁在一起
你要怎麼跟一個
可能作弊的人來往
密西根大學的Robert Axelrod
辦過一場電腦比賽
讓各種玩法互相對打
贏的是最簡單的一套
叫Tit for Tat
中文叫以牙還牙
開頭先合作
之後對方上一輪
怎麼對你就怎麼對他
真的動物也這樣玩嗎
先看吸血蝙蝠
好幾只母蝙蝠住在同一個窩
它們吸了血
存在喉嚨的一個囊袋裡
飛回來吐出來
喂窩裡所有的孩子
不管是不是自己的
研究的人抓住一隻母蝙蝠
用針筒往它的囊袋裡打空氣
打得鼓鼓的再放回去
其他母蝙蝠看到的是
它明明吸飽了
卻不餵我們的孩子
下一次其他母蝙蝠就不喂他的孩子
這就是以牙還牙
連蝙蝠都會算這筆賬
研究的人做的
就是故意製造一次誤會
看他們怎麼反應
規則有了
Sapolsky回到桌上那兩個頭骨
讓全慢一起推
第一種情況
公的頭骨比母的大很多
全齒又長又尖
那公的一定很常打架
搶的是交配的機會
結果是少數幾隻公的
拿走了大部分的交配
其他的一輩子都沒有後代
這一型叫Tournament Species
中文叫錦標賽型物種
像沸沸
銀家通吃
母的既然只從公的身上拿到基因
就挑最好的基因
紅雀
那一大片尾巴就這樣來了
第二種情況
兩個頭骨一樣大
這一型叫pair bonding
中文叫配對結合
公的跟母的長期在一起
一起養孩子
像南美洲的龍猴
公的很少打架
爸爸帶孩子的力氣
有時候比媽媽還多
所以母龍猴
幾乎每次都生雙胞胎
兩隻都養得活
只看一個特徵
就推出一整套生活
那人類呢
男人跟女人的提醒差距
不像沸沸那麼大
也不像龍猴一樣大
爸爸帶孩子的程度也在中間
大部分文化允許一夫多妻
可是大部分人過的是一夫一妻
Sapolsky說
我們是一個很困惑的物種
這條規則最有力的時候
是他能解釋一件大家最不想接受的事
1970年代
研究者Sara Hardy在印度觀察一種叫夜猴的猴子
發現公猴會殺小猴
這個叫Infanticide
中文叫殺鷹
大家第一個反應是
這群猴子一定出了問題
可是後來在獅子大猩猩
很多物種身上都看到
而且他有規律
殺的是新來的公的
殺的是別的公的孩子
而且只出現在一種物種裡
母的餵奶不排卵的那幾年
比一隻公的能當老大的時間還長
你是一隻剛打敗老大的公猴
所有母猴都在餵奶
要等好幾年才會再懷孕
可是你等不到那時候
殺掉小猴
母猴停止餵奶
很快又會排卵
這是冷冰冰的算術
母猴又有對策
她已經懷孕
卻裝出發情的樣子
新公猴跟她交配
幾個星期後孩子出生
公猴不會去算懷孕要多久
就不殺了
Sapolsky說
公侯每次都上當
規則沒有好壞
他只是把每一方的算盤
都攤在桌上
到這裡這套規則
看起來無所不能
1975年
E.O. Wilson出了一本書
叫《社會生物學》
說有一天所有社會科學
都會歸到演化生物學底下
Sapolsky接著講
他被批評的地方
這套想法背後有三個假設
行為能遺傳
每個特徵都有用
演化一點一點慢慢變
第一個
假設被分子遺傳學的人
罵得最兇
社會生物學的證明
是倒著來的
分子遺傳學的人說
那你把那個基因拿出來給我看
第二個假設
被兩位哈佛教授
Gould跟Ruanting挑戰
他們借了建築的一個詞
叫Spandrel
中文叫拱肩
兩個拱門並排
中間一定會多出一塊三角形的牆
他沒有目的
只是蓋拱門就躲不掉
人是靈長類裡唯一有下巴的
有人努力研究哈巴有什麼好處
後來才發現
臉變短了
下巴就自己突出來
不是每樣東西都是為了什麼
這兩個批評問的
其實是同一件事
你說的故事很好聽
可是證據在哪裡
第三個假設
是演化一點一點慢慢變
如果每一代多一點點好處
就能多留一點點基因
那每一點好處都值得搶
所以才會有殺因
看起來一切都是競爭
而Good跟另一位古生物學家
Niles Eldridge提出另一種看法
叫Punctuated Equilibrium
中文叫斷續平衡
意思是
演化大部分時間什麼都沒發生
很長很長的平靜
然後突然在很短的時間裡大變一次
畫出來不是一條斜坡
是一階一階的樓梯
這場爭論還帶著政治
批評的人說
第一代社會生物學家
把競爭跟階級說成天生的
真巧
剛好讓自己這種人得利
另一邊的good是馬克思主義者
他的樓梯
剛好是少一點競爭
偶爾來一場大變動
1970年代末的一場研討會上
還有人衝上臺
把水倒在Wilson頭上
所以Polsky說
兩邊都有自己的立場
科學的問題
不過因為誰的立場
比較討喜就有答案
要分出誰對
得看基因到底在做什麼
我們先停一下
把前三堂課收起來
這一部分回答的是
為什麼一個解釋不夠
因為人會分類
分類讓你記得住
也讓你看不清
每一門學問都是一個籃子
所以我們沿著時間往回問
走到最遠的一站
演化
那裡的規則是
動物做事不是為了物種好
是讓基因留下越多分越好
有自己身幫親戚
有來有往
三種做法
它準備讓人意外
從兩個頭骨就推出一整套生活
連沙音都算得出來
它也有管不到的地方
拱門中間的三角形提醒我們
不是每樣東西都有用途
一階一階的樓梯提醒我們
演化不一定是一點一點變
可是最根本的
是他背後有一個
沒被證明的假設
行為能遺傳
這個假設不是隨便說說
因為他背後有一句話
行為是寫在基因裡的
如果這句話錯了
前面那些漂亮的推理
就都少了一塊地基
沒跟上的話
記住這一句
演化是很強的樂臺
但還是樂臺
下一站
我們照批評的人說的
把基因拿出來看
第四堂課
Zapolsky說
這門課前半段的任務
就是從一個籃子
跳到另一個籃子
你剛覺得住得舒服
就換一個學門
來找他的麻煩
他的意思是
一個學門覺得
問題已經回答完了
常常正好是下一個學門
開始的地方
這一次輪到分子生物學的人
他們看社會生物學的證明方式
只覺得不屑
一個最好聽的故事就算贏
這也算科學
我們先把基因是什麼講清楚
一個基因
一段DNA
他記得是怎麼做出一個蛋白質
蛋白質是細胞裡
真正在做事的東西
傳遞訊息靠它
加快化學反應靠它
細胞的骨架也是它搭起來的
蛋白質能做事靠的是形狀
Sepolsky讓全班一起說出那句老話
像鎖跟鑰匙
一個荷蒙的形狀
剛好插進一個受體的凹槽
訊號就傳過去了
所以只要知道DNA的順序
你就知道蛋白質長什麼樣子
也就知道它會做什麼
發現DNA結構的Francis Crick
把這條路叫做Central Dogma
中文叫中心法則
意思是資訊從DNA流到蛋白質
DNA是發號失令的那一個
請你記住發號失令這四個字
等一下它就站不住了
那基因出錯會怎樣
DNA像一串用四個字母寫成的句子
這個叫Mutation
中文叫體變
就是其中一個字母被抄錯了
有時候抄錯了也沒差
因為好幾種寫法指的是同一個意思
就像同一句話有好幾種講法
有時候差很多
一個字錯了
整句的意思就變了
身體裡有一種東西叫苯丙胺酸
太多會傷害腦子
平常有一種酵素
負責把它轉成安全的東西
只要做這個要素的基因
錯一個字母
要素就不工作
苯丙胺酸越積越多
孩子的腦子受損
這個病叫PKU
中文叫苯酮尿症
這個名字請你記住
第七堂課它會再出現
而且結局不一樣
不過大部分的圖片沒有這麼戲劇化
他們只是讓鑰匙的形狀偏一點點
插進鎖裡松一點
或者緊一點
蛋白質做事的效率好一點
或差一點
好一點點就多留一點點基因
一代一代累積
這就是一條慢慢往上的斜坡
這正是第一部分那些演化推理需要的畫面
每一點好處都算數
每一點都值得競爭
所以古典遺傳學剛好替慢慢編那個假設說話
接下來是這一堂課最重要的發現
大家原本以為DNA從頭到尾都是基因
一個接一個排
結果一算
雖然人類的DNA超過95%根本不做蛋白質
一開始有人叫他拉蓋DNA
可是你的DNA絕大部分怎麼可能只是填充物
後來大家才懂
那是說明書寫的是
每個基因什麼時候開
什麼時候關在身體的哪個地方開
開多大
我們用房子裡的燈來想
基因是燈泡
那九成以上的DNA
是滿強的開關跟線路
開關有名字叫Promoter
中文叫啟動值
就是接在一個基因前面的那一段
換句話說每個基因前面都有一個專屬的開關
來按開關的東西
叫Conscription Factor
中文叫轉入因子
它的形狀剛好卡進啟動值
一卡進去
那個基因就開始做蛋白質
更妙的是
同一種啟動值
可以擠在很多個基因前面
一個轉入因子按下去
一整排燈同時亮
所以基因要說的
從來不是一道命令
而是一句
如果這個開關被按下
就做這件事
那誰來按開關
這是整堂課最關鍵的一個問題
答案是外面
第一種外面是細胞自己
細胞快沒能量了
某個轉入因子被叫醒
去打開一批負責搬進養分的基因
第二種外面
是身體的另一頭
碳固酮從膽管出發
順著血液流到肌肉卡進肌肉細胞的受體
打開一批讓肌肉長大的基因
第三種
外面真的是身體外面
一隻剛生產的母鼠
聞到自己孩子的氣味訊號一路傳進去
打開做荷爾蒙的基因
他更投入照顧孩子
你注意到了嗎
這三個例子裡
基因本身一個字都沒改
改的是誰在什麼時候按下開關
同一個基因在不同的時候
不同的地方
做的事可以差很多
Zapolsky說得很直接
DNA不知道自己在做什麼
燈泡不會自己決定要不要亮
一個基因要不要作用
是由細胞 身體
甚至整個世界發生的是決定的
這裡要用一個很重要的詞
environment 環境
環境不只是你住在哪個城市
吃什麼 被誰養大
細胞裡的能量
液液裡的荷爾蒙
鼻子聞到的氣味
對 基因來說都是環境
有些開關按下去
會卡住
很久都不回來
基因外面包著一層蛋白質
可以把DNA卷緊
卷得很緊的地方
轉入因子擠不進去
那個基因就等於被關掉了
研究這種變化的學問
叫Epigenetics
中文叫錶冠遺傳學
前面的開關是按一下
放開就回來
錶冠遺傳像是有人
在開關上貼了一塊膠帶
他研究的不是DNA寫了什麼
而是DNA哪些地方讀得到
最有名的例子
來自加拿大麥基爾大學的
Michael Meaney
有些老鼠媽媽很常舔孩子
幫孩子理毛
有些很少
常被舔的小老鼠
長大以後比較不緊張
面對壓力恢復得比較快
原因就在開關
被舔得多的小老鼠
跟壓力荷爾蒙有關的基因
開關的狀態不一樣
而且維持到長大
他當然媽媽也比較會舔孩子
這個痘子就一代一代傳下去
可是傳的不是基因
好消息是
這個開關不是旱死的
把小老鼠換給一個
很會舔的媽媽帶
開關還能轉回來
Zaposki送了一句話給我們
受精講的是遺傳
發育講的是錶冠遺傳
你拿到的基因
在受精那一刻就定了
可是哪些基因讀得到
是長大的過程一路寫上去的
第五堂課
Zaposki把這些開關接回演化
改基因本身
像換一個燈泡
頂多讓某盞燈亮一點或暗一點
可是改一個開關
就可能讓一整排燈在新的時間
新的地方亮起來
一個例子是田鼠
有些田鼠很專一
公的跟母的一輩子在一起
有些田鼠很不專一
差別跟一種荷爾蒙的獸體有關
叫加加素獸體
獸體就是接受荷爾蒙的那個鎖孔
這個獸體基因本身幾乎一樣
差別在它前面那段開關
讓獸體出現在腦子裡的不同地方
研究的人在不專業的公田鼠腦中某一區
多放一些這種獸體
他就開始只黏著同一個伴侶
一個開關的位置不同
一種動物的婚姻制度就跟著不同
另一個例子更大
1970年代
伯克萊的Mary Claire King跟Alan Wilson
亮出人跟黑猩猩的蛋白質幾乎一模一樣
於是大膽猜
我們跟黑猩猩的差別主要不在零件
而在開關
後來很多研究都往這個方向走
這對演化是個好消息
要做出一種很不一樣的動物
不用重新發明零件
改幾個開關就夠了
開關還能搬家
這要講一位科學家
Barbara McClintock
他研究玉米
看一粒一粒玉米的顏色怎麼遺傳
40歲出頭就被選進美國國家科學院
是那個年代最頂尖的遺傳學家之一
有一天
他算出一個很怪的結論
唯一的解釋是
基因會在DNA上跳來跳去
這個叫transposin
中文叫轉位置
大傢俬下叫他跳躍基因
那時候很多人覺得他瘋了
他沒有吵
繼續回到玉米田做他的實驗
幾十年後
分子生物學的工具追上來
證明他是對的
他80多歲拿到諾貝爾獎
Zapposki也說
這段歷史常被講得太悲壯
其實當時也有人懂他
只是他的論文很難讀
Zapposki見過他一次
說他那時候90歲左右
很客氣
但很明顯只想趕快回去照顧他的玉米
跳躍基因重要在哪裡
一段開關跳到別的基因前面
就等於寫出一句
從來沒有過的
如果怎樣就怎樣
Zapposki舉了一個想象的例子
原本是
如果壓力荷爾蒙多
就壓低免疫力
要是負責接收荷爾蒙的那一段
換成懷孕荷爾蒙的版本
就變成如果懷孕了
就壓低免疫力
媽媽的身體就比較不會攻擊胎兒
我們現在回答脅迫跟樓梯
改一個開關
影響的是一整群基因
這種大改變
碰巧整群都變好的機會非常小
絕大部分是災難
就像你把一棟房子的總開關
亂接一通
碰巧每個房間都更好用的機會
幾乎是零
所以大部分時間
任何大改變都會被淘汰
族群停在原地
這就是樓梯上那段長長的平臺
那什麼時候會跳一階
當環境壞到極點
大部分個體都活不下來
只有剛好帶著某種怪特質的少數熬過去
這個叫Bottleneck
中文叫瓶頸
獵豹就是栗子
今天的獵豹
鼻子太像
一直獵豹的皮膚移植到另一隻身上
幾乎不會排斥
他們都是一小群倖存者的後代
演化也可以快得出奇
一位蘇聯遺傳學家
Dimitri Beliaev
養銀狐
每一代只讓最不怕人的狐狸繁殖
只選了幾十代
這些狐狸就會咬尾巴
耳朵變軟
嘴巴變短
毛色變得花花的
看起來像小狗
他只選了個性
外表整套跟著變
因為這些特徵背後
很可能是同一批開關
Sapolsky的結論是
斜坡跟樓梯不用二選一
零件的小改變
在爬斜坡
開關的大改變在跳樓梯
兩個都在發生
我們再停一下
把分子遺傳學收起來
這一部分回答的是
把基因拿出來看
他到底在做什麼
答案是基因很少
直接下命令
做零件的那小段DNA
決定蛋白質的形狀
改一個字母
多半是讓它好一點或差一點
這是斜坡
超過九成的DNA是開關
他們把基因寫成一句一句的
如果怎樣就怎樣
改一個開關
一整排燈跟著變
這是樓梯
所以演化裡的斜坡跟樓梯
都找得到分子上的原因
第一部分留下的第三個假設
在這裡有了答案
兩種都對
最要緊的是
暗開關的常常是外面
細胞
荷爾蒙
氣味
甚至媽媽舔了你幾下
那第一個假設呢
行為能遺傳嗎
現在的答案變成
基因確實參與了行為
可是他參與的方式
是等外面的訊號
沒跟上的話
記住這一句
基因說的是
如果的那一半在外面
這就帶出下一個問題
既然基因跟環境
纏在一起
有沒有辦法算出
一個行為幾成是天生的
有一整個學門
專門在算這個數字
他給的答案
常常上新聞
也常常被誤解
第六堂課
又換一個籃子
叫Behavior Genetics
中文叫行為遺傳學
這一派的人
不編演化故事
也不找突變
他們看的是
但是越親的人行為是不是越像
Sapolsky先放了一張漫畫
兩個科學家在實驗室
一個說
你知道有時候講電話講很久
對方想掛又不好意思說
就說我不耽誤你了吧
我好像找到那個的基因了
這就是很多人對這一行的印象
什麼行為都能找到一個基因
Sapolsky要我們看的是
他們用來證明的工具
到底靠不靠得住
最簡單的證據是
某個行為在家族裡代代相傳
可是家族裡傳的不只有基因還有環境
那就比較雙胞胎
同卵雙胞胎
基因幾乎一模一樣
異卵雙胞胎
的心地姐妹一樣
大約只有一半
如果兩種雙胞胎
都在同一個家長大
同卵的比較像
就代表是基因
問題是
同卵雙胞胎長得一樣
爸媽跟老師
對待他們也更一樣
連在媽媽肚子裡
有些同卵雙胞胎
還共用一個胎盤
環境從一開始
就沒有被控制住
那就讓基因
跟環境分開
第一種做法
是看被收養的孩子
1960年代
Simo Ketty的團隊
到丹麥
因為那裡的記錄最完整
他們找出所有被收養
後來得了
思覺失調症的人
思覺失調症就是
以前說的精神分裂症
再去查他們的
親生父母跟養父母
結果是
就算一出生就被抱走
從來沒跟親生父母住過
親生父母有這個病的孩子
得病的機會
還是明顯高很多
這是早期
很紮實的一個證據
說一種精神疾病
有遺傳的成分
第二種做法更理想
一出生就被分開了
同軟雙胞胎
明尼蘇達大學的
Tom Bouchard
找了好幾百對
這種雙胞胎
這些雙胞胎重逢的故事
在家庭長大重逢以後
大家發現兩個人上廁所前
都會先沖一次水
這種很怪的相似
登上了報紙
可是真正有份量的
是大量雙胞胎累積起來的統計
智商 外向程度這些樂子
同卵雙胞胎分開長大也還是很像
可是這些研究也有漏洞
收養機構會刻意把孩子放進
跟原生家庭相似的家庭
分開長大的雙胞胎
環境其實沒有那麼不一樣
這些方法有一個共同的前提
環境從出生那一刻才開始
Sapolsky說
這個前提錯了
1944年冬天
荷蘭西部被德軍封鎖
糧食運不進來
一個本來期的還算正常的地方
突然陷入饑荒
一直到隔年春天才解放
那個冬天還在媽媽肚子裡的胎兒
透過媽媽的血
學到一件事
外面的食物很少
於是身體把自己調成一種模式
這個叫thrifty phenotype
中文可以叫節減體質
它的意思是
吃進來的每一點熱量
都儘量存起來
鹽分也緊緊留住
問題是
戰爭結束
他們長大以後吃的是正常的飯
一個為饑荒準備的身體
碰上吃得飽的世界
肥胖 血糖 血壓出問題的比例都比較高
有意思的是
時間點很要緊
同一場饑荒
出生以後才碰上的嬰兒
就沒有這麼明顯的效果
甚至有研究說
連他們的下一代都看得到一點因子
一個在嬰兒出生後才開始觀察的研究者
看到孩子跟媽媽一樣容易胖
會以為他看到的是遺傳
其實那是媽媽肚子裡的環境
兔子裡能學到的
不只是食物多不多
有一個研究
請懷孕的媽媽在最後幾個星期
每天大聲念同一本童書
蘇斯博士的戴帽子的貓
孩子出生以後
研究的人讓新生兒
氣一個會記錄動作的奶嘴
吸法不同
就播不同的故事
結果新生兒比較愛聽那本聽過的書
他還沒出生就已經熟悉一個故事的節奏
如果你只在他出生以後才開始觀察
你會以為他天生就偏愛這本書
另一個實驗更直接
有兩種老鼠
一種很容易緊張
一種很冷靜
一代一代都是這樣
看起來就是遺傳
研究的人把容易緊張那種的胚胎
移到冷靜那種媽媽的肚子裡
生下來也由他帶大
結果長大以後是冷靜的
還有一件事
連爸爸媽媽給的東西都不是一半一半
細胞裡負責產生能量的立線體
有自己的一小段DNA
而它只從媽媽那邊來
所以你看到一個痘子比較像媽媽
不一定是兔子裡的環境
也可能是遺傳
本來就不對稱
這些都讓天生幾成變得更難算
媽媽給的比我們以為的多
也比我們以為的早
後來工具進步
研究人可以直接找基因了
做法有兩個方向
一個是從行為出發
找一大家族
比對有病的人跟沒病的人
DNA差在哪一段
另一個是從動物研究出發
先知道一個基因在老鼠身上做什麼
再看人類的不同版本
有沒有對應的差別
還記得田鼠的加壓素受體嗎
人類男性也有不同版本的那段開關
有一份研究發現
帶著某個版本的人
伴侶關係比較容易出問題
跟冒險焦慮有關的基因
也一個一個被找出來
聽起來很驚人
新聞標題也最愛這種發現
可是Saposky特別強調
這些基因每一個
都只解釋一點點差異
另外還有一種狀況更容易騙人
心理學家Judith Rich Harris
提出一個可能
外向
這個個性看起來很能遺傳
可是真正遺傳下去的
也許是身高跟長相
長得高
長得好看的孩子
被大家對待得比較好
就變得比較外向
這種情況
叫間接的基因效果
基因推動的是
別人怎麼對你
在推動你
行為遺傳學
最後都會給你一個數字
叫heritability
中文叫遺傳率
比如說某個特質的遺傳率很高
大部分人以為
這是在說
基因決定了這個特質的幾成
Sapolsky說
不是這樣
這個數字講的不是平均值
而是差異
他回答的是
當然他這個特質得上不一樣
這些不一樣有多少來自基因
這兩件事聽起來很像
其實差很多
每件事
有沒有寫在基因裡
跟大家在這件事上的差別
從哪裡來
是兩個問題
他舉了兩個例子
人有幾根手指
當然是基因決定的
每個人都是五根
可是你問
那些不是五根的人是怎麼回事
幾乎都是意外
工廠的機器
廚房的刀
差異全部來自環境
所以手指數目的遺傳率是0
再看1950年代的美國
女人出門幾乎都戴耳環
男人幾乎沒有人戴
一個人戴不戴耳環
只要知道性別就猜得到
而性別是基因決定的
所以那個年代
戴耳環的遺傳率是100%
手指頭0 耳環100
這就是開場那一題的答案
遺傳率說的是差異從哪裡來
不是這件事有沒有寫在基因裡
為什麼會這麼繞
西波斯基自己也承認
這是整門課最難懂的一個概念
他用一株想像的植物講清楚
這種植物同一個基因有ABC三個版本
亞馬遜雨林亮這種植物
發現三個版本長得高矮差很多
他很興奮
基因決定一切
另一位研究生在隔壁沙漠亮同一種植物
也發現三個版本差很多
兩個人在研討會上碰面
把數字放在一起
才發現雨林裡的每一株
都比沙漠裡的任何一株高得多
Sapolsky給一個最好用的問題
如果你只能知道一件事
你要知道它是哪個版本的基因
還是它長在哪裡
這個例子裡
你一定選長在哪裡
這就是遺傳率很低的樣子
麻煩的是
但是科學家做實驗
本來就被教要控制環境
只在一個地方一種條件下量
環境被固定住了
看起來的差異
就全落在基因上
所以越乾淨的實驗越容易高估基因
這不是科學家偷懶
是實驗設計本身的盲點
而人類
剛好是住過最多種環境的物種
有時候答案更麻煩
假設在雨林版本C長得最高
到了沙漠版本C反而最矮
那你問版本C對這株植物有什麼影響
唯一誠實的答案是
看情況
看它長在哪裡
這個叫Gene-environment interaction
中文叫基因與環境的交互作用
真實世界有現成的例子
還記得本酮尿症嗎
錯一個字母
腦子就受損
看起來遺傳率是100%
可是現在的做法是
從小吃不含苯丙氨酸的飲食
腦子就正常長大
環境一改
遺傳率就從100變成0
另一個例子
是Ephraim Caspi的團隊
追蹤紐西蘭一整批人長大
發現一個跟血清素有關的基因
血清素是腦子裡傳遞訊息的一種化學物質
某個版本的人
只有在童年經歷很多壓力的時候
才特別容易憂鬱
後來更大的研究
對這個基因吵得很兇
有的重現不出來
可是看情況這個想法
留了下來
Sapolsky在講義上引了一句話
問基因跟環境哪一個比較重要
就像問一個長方形的面積
是長比較重要還是寬比較重要
有這些想法
一碰到真實社會
就很有分量
1980年代
約翰霍普金斯大學的
Benbow跟Stanley
分析幾萬名
參加自由計劃的國中生
發現數學考很高分的那一群裡
男生遠遠多過女生
他們在論文裡說
這個年紀大家上的數學課都一樣
環境相同
所以差別來自生物
當時的雜誌標題寫
男生有數學基因嗎
Sapolsky說
這個前提早就錯了
從小學開始
同樣舉手
老師比較常點男生
同樣答對
男生比較常被稱讚
後來有一篇研究
比較幾十個國家的學生
看這個國家的男女有多平等
結果越平等的國家
數學的男女差距越小
到了最平等的那一端
差距幾乎消失
冰島甚至是女生略好一點
以頂尖那一群裡的男女比例
20年來縮小了一大截
人類的基因
不可能在20年裡變這麼多
一個德職20年就大幅改變
說明推動它的主要是環境
這不是說男生女生沒有任何差別
而是說
這個差別大部分跟著社會走
要猜兩個人誰的數學比較好
與其問性別
不如問他在哪裡長大
第八堂課一開始
Sapolsky跟全班開了一個玩笑
他說
早上報紙登了一個大研究
尼泊爾人玩蛇踢棋
比比利時人厲害
大家開始問問題
樣本多大
他說兩國全國人民都參加了
有沒有控制環境
每個人連胚胎都被換到第三個國家寄養
大家一路問下去
最後才有人問出那個最重要的問題
差多少
還要大家記住
結果很可靠跟一個結果很重要
是兩回事
接著他舉了一個真的研究
挪威把幾十萬個18歲年輕人的智力測驗成績
按出生順序比較
發現老大的分數比老二高
研究做得很漂亮
樣本大
控制得仔細
連老大找妖老二變成家裡最大的
分數也會跟著像老大
這都查到了
可是差距小到什麼程度
Sapolsky說
你考試的時候打個噴嚏
差幾秒鼻子
大概差不多掉這麼多分
這個工具
接下來每次看到新研究都用得上
先問可不可考
再問差距有多大
接著Sapolsky回到
親屬選擇留下的那個疑問
親屬選擇要成立
動物得先知道誰是親戚
而且知道有多親
他們怎麼知道
答案有三種
剛好對應我們走過的三個籃子
第一種是天生的
靠鼻子
每隻動物身上有一組基因
叫MHC
中文叫主要組織相容性複合體
名字很長
你只要記得它的工作
它會做出一個
幾乎每隻動物都不一樣的身份標記
免疫系統靠它分辨自己人跟外來的細菌
這個標記也會混在尿液跟汗水裡
越親的親戚
標記越像
老鼠聞一聞
就知道對方是兄弟表情還是陌生的
連精子都分得出來
有一種到處交配的路鼠
精子會跟同一只公鼠的精子抱成一團
遊得比較快
第二種要靠血
母山羊生下小羊以後
很快記住牠身上的氣味
之後只餵餵起來對著那一隻
第三種靠推理
Szabowski說
一群廢廢裡
公廢廢會記得
母廢廢最可能懷孕的那幾天
是跟誰在一起
越可能是自己的孩子
那就越常照顧
你看
同一件事
認親期
基因 學期 思考
三個籃子各給一種做法
而且在很多動物身上
是三種一起用
那人類呢
我們以為自己全靠推理
這是我媽媽
因為大家都這樣告訴我
可是新生兒出生沒多久
就分得出媽媽身上的味道
也認得媽媽的聲音
那是在兔子裡聽了好幾個月的聲音
最有意思的證據
來自以色列的集體農場
叫Kibbutz
早期的集體農場
同一年出生的孩子一起住
一起吃飯一起洗澡
人類學家研究
這些孩子長大以後的婚姻
發現六歲以前
在同一群一起長大的人
彼此之間幾乎沒有人結婚
他們很親
可是感覺就像兄弟姐妹
史丹佛的人類學家
Arthur Wolf
在臺灣找到同一件事
傳統的同養媳
從小被帶到未來丈夫家一起長大
這種離婚比較多孩子比較少
這是一句寫在我們身上的
如果怎樣就怎樣
如果六歲以前天天在一起就當成家人
規則是天生的
可是誰算家人
是環境填進去的
跟燈牆上的開關一模一樣
開關早就裝好了
按下去的是童年
Sapolsky提醒
這也代表我們很容易被操弄
軍隊讓一群陌生人覺得彼此是兄弟
戰爭宣傳讓對面的人看起來不像人
誰是我們
誰是他們
可以被改寫
後面講攻擊跟合作的課
這件事會一再回來
我們最後停一下
因為幾成是天生的
答案是
這個問題本身問錯了
不是因為科學家不夠努力
是因為基因跟環境
本來就不是兩堆
可以分開稱重的東西
雙胞胎跟收養研究
每一個都被環境偷偷滲進來
而且環境不是從出生
才開始在媽媽肚子裡就開始了
遺傳率
講的是差異從哪裡來
所以手指頭是0
耳環是100
就算真的找到基因
每一個也只推動一點點
而且常常要看他碰到什麼環境
這也回答了
開場那個40歲的男人
就算他真的有一個基因出錯
那個基因什麼時候發作
發作成什麼樣子
還是要看他碰到什麼
還記得一開始
John Watson那句話嗎
給我一個嬰兒
我可以把它變成任何人
他把一切丟進後天的籃子
說基因決定一切的人
把一切丟進先天的籃子
兩邊住的是同一種籃子
都以為一邊就能解釋全部
沒跟上的話
記住這一句
問基因跟環境哪一個重要
就像問長方形
是長重要還是寬重要
我們回到開場那個問題
一個人做了一件事
是天生的還是後天的
這巴巴克走了三步
第一步一個解釋不夠
每一門學問都是一個籃子
可是他假設行為能遺傳
第二步把基因拿出來
才發現基因很少下命令
他說的是
如果怎樣就怎樣
按開關的常常在外面
第三步
想算出天生幾成
才發現這個問題問錯了
基因跟環境
像長方形的長跟寬分不開
所以這一集的答案還是那句
難得不是找到一個解釋
是不要只住在一個解釋裡
還記得那個40歲的男人嗎
品格
中年危機
一個基因
三個答案
可能都只說對了一段
而且這三段是連在一起的
接下來的課
Sapolsky會再跳進新的籃子
先到野外看研究動物行為的人怎麼觀察
再一路走進神經跟荷爾蒙
也就是從一秒前那幾站開始看
最後問你一個問題
你身上有沒有一個特質
你一直以為是天生的
後來才發現
是某個環境把它的開關打開的
留言告訴我
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
我們下次見